it's very difficult I think for modern
young people in particular to really
understand
how poor people were absolutely
yeah absolutely the best the best
example I like to use is the sugar
example and it's like well the time it
took you to earn the money to buy one
pound of sugar in 1850 how many pounds
do you think you could get today I'd
love to serve my students on this and
they'll say oh like two pounds or four
pounds you get 227 pounds
it might explain why we're also fat is
because sugar has become just
tremendously abundant
[Music]
hello everyone I have with me today
a guest I've had on before Dr Marion
tupian a new guest his co-author at the
moment of a new book called Super
abundance the story of population growth
Innovation and human flourishing on an
infinitely Bountiful Planet 2022 it's
the most complete opposite of any
apocalyptic title you might ever
Envision Marion has talked to me before
particularly about his book 10 Global
Trends every smart person should know
and many others you will find
interesting that was published in 2020
Marion is the editor of human
progress.org which is a very good site
and I retweet them quite consistently
he's a senior fellow at the center for
Global liberty and prosperity and the
co-author of that Simon abundance index
which we will talk about to some degree
today he specializes in globalization
study of globalization
um and Global well-being and politics
and the economics of Europe and southern
Africa
Dr Gail pulley is associate professor of
business management at Brigham Young
University at Hawaii he's taught
economics and statistics at alfazo
University in Riyadh Saudi Arabia
Brigham Young in Idaho Boise State
University in the College of Idaho he
earned his BBA and economics and Boise
State in The Graduate work at Montana
State completed his PhD at the
University of Idaho
he's
been part of the development of the
Simon abundance index as well and as I
said is the co-author of this new book
super abundance
which is a lot different than
apocalyptic Doom as I pointed out
um both of doctors tupi and Gail have
published widely in the public domain as
well as professionally in Outlets like
Financial Times the National Review the
uh particularly evil Journal quilette
Forbes the American spectator The
Washington Post Etc any of your what
would you call them
traditional suspects or Usual Suspects
so anyways we're going to talk about
this new book today super abundance a
three-part 10 chapter analysis of why
strangely enough things seem to be a lot
better than we think and perhaps better
than they ever were and uh
although we're more concerned about it
than we ever seem to have been before so
welcome gentlemen thank you very much
for agreeing to talk to me and
congratulations on your new book thank
you very much I'm delighted to be with
you
yeah so let's uh let's start with super
abundance
um I don't know whether to start with
with Julian Simon's famous bet that's
not a it's kind of a nice narrative
entry point eh
um I think that's uh that's right yeah
all right well so why don't you why do
you outline for for our listeners and
viewers the nature of this famous bat
why it was made and what it what its
broader cultural significance was
because it was really a watershed bat I
think in many ways
well so in the post-second World War era
uh Global populations started to grow at
a much faster rate than before uh partly
because of a tremendous amount of
medical and scientific knowledge that
started to spread around the world uh
babies started to
um you know if your babies started to
die young people started to grow long um
grow older and so forth and um some
people started to freak out about it
they thought that there was going to be
too many people in the world and
consequently we were going to run out of
resources prices of resources were going
to go Sky High and there would be Mass
starvation now the man who brought this
particular Obsession or potential
problem into the public sphere was Paul
Ehrlich who still is alive he's a
biologist at Stanford University and in
1968 still causing trouble still causing
trouble still to uh yeah and uh in 1968
he wrote an extremely popular books book
which sold millions of copies uh called
the population bomb and the population
bomb started in a sort of very
terrifying language that we have become
accustomed to from extreme
environmentalists over the decades and
he basically said no matter what policy
changes we are going to make now uh in
the 1970s hundreds of millions of people
are going to die due to starvation in
fact none of that happened nonetheless
um Paul early's book the population bomb
scared and scarred psychologically
generations of people
um movies had been made about how the
world was going to run out of resources
and and in a catastrophe the one of the
more famous ones was with Charlton
Heston uh it was called Soylent Green
and uh uh the reason why it's important
is because Soylent Green whilst it was
filmed in 1974 was supposed to come to
fruition in 2022 which is this year and
the basic premise of the book was that
the world was completely empty of food
and so every time a person died that
person would be converted into biscuits
called soil and green which would be
then fed to the people who stayed behind
so uh on the other side right so so a
lot of this just to give some background
to that too a lot of this was based on
hypothetical biological thinking uh
predicated on the work of Malthus and
it's sort of a yeast or rat model of
human existence so if you have a colony
of yeast and you and they have a finite
uh medium that they're growing in so a
finite
source of food
and you let the yeast multiply or let
them know
provide them with the preconditions for
their multiplication their population
will expand until they consume all the
available resources and then it will
precipitate precipitously collapse in
Starvation and people tried similar
although less
simple experiments with rats showing
similar behavior and then I would say
documented similar phenomena in the
field I mean animals will
over graze for example if their
herbivores will overgraze available crop
land if they're not kept in check so to
speak by predators and biologists
extrapolated from this and said that
under all other things being equal
populations will expand until they
consume more available resources than
will sustain them and then they will
tend to precipitously collapse and then
that was applied to the human condition
but the as we see from the rest of your
story The economists objected to this
yes so the view that just you just
described is particularly popular
amongst
amongst biologists economists don't
think like that because they recognize
that human beings are fundamentally
different from rats or deer or rabbits
or whatever else or Yeast or Yeast we
have this thing called intelligence and
the ability to apply these little gray
cells in order to come up with
Innovations which can get around the
problem of scarcity so on the other side
of the country early as I said was in
Stanford in California on the other side
of the country in in the University of
Maryland uh there was an economist
called Julian Simon uh a a very uh very
intelligent and very interesting man who
looked at the data actually and started
noticing that things were becoming
cheaper which means that they were
becoming less scarce even though
population of the world continued to
increase therefore in 1980 he made a bet
with Paul Ehrlich and the BET was on the
price of five Commodities let me see if
I can remember them the the the BET was
on the price of chromium copper nickel
tin and tungsten and the deal was as
this as such
if over the next 10 years between 1980
and 1990 the price of these five Metals
became more expensive
they became scarcer
Simon would pay Ehrlich but if they
became cheaper then erlig would pay
Simon well the BET came to an end in
1919 September 29 1990 and the inflation
adjusted price of these five Metals
dropped by 36 percent in spite of the
fact that the population of the world
arose by almost a billion and in spite
of the fact that they both agreed that
that would be the basket they would bet
on actually Ehrlich picked the the
basket yes Simon was uh Simon was uh
generous enough he said
Paul Ehrlich pick any five Commodities
or any any five Commodities you want and
those were the ones that early picked
well what's so interesting about that I
think well there's many many things that
are interesting about it but one of the
things that's so interesting is that
you might infer from that that in order
to put your notion forward as a
scientific hypothesis you actually have
to bind it with a time frame you can't
just say well at some point in the
future the population is going to expand
to the point where we consume all our
resources it's like well what do you
mean you mean a year 10 years a hundred
a thousand ten thousand a hundred and
fifty thousand a million you mean you
get to have the whole time frame for you
to be right or no are you accurate
enough in your knowledge so that you can
actually pin it down let's say within a
decade or something some reasonable
fraction of a human life at least and so
because I mean the biologists who when
they responded to that bet because it
was quite the cultural what moment in
some sense that Simon won the rejoinder
from the environmentalist Doom types was
well we were off by a few decades and
that's why we lost it isn't that we're
wrong it's just that these things are
complex and our time frame was wrong
it's like yeah if your time frame is
wrong then your theory is wrong
and if you can't place the time frame
around it then your theory is so weak
that you should just be quiet about it
and I think the same thing applies to
all this climate Doom as well it's like
specify it well we can't it's too
complex well then quit terrifying
everyone
you know another thing that was
interesting about it is uh you know as
professors we get to say all kinds of
things and never be really held
accountable for it and so putting money
on the table you know also added this
really interesting Dimension to it is
not only is it framed in time it's
framed with with a bet so got to hold
this guy accountable for his uh for his
claim some skin in the game well and
then there's a reputational issue too
right because it was a very public bet
and it was it wasn't so famous when they
first made it but by the time it came
around for the BET to be settled and I
would say this is particularly true of
Julian Simon who we should talk about
for a moment
um
Paul Air like's a pretty smart biologist
but Julian Simon was a genius
and so that's useful for people to know
too I mean he was a truly outstanding
mind and for him to be optimistic in the
face of what was almost a universal
pessimism in the late 60s and early 70s
around well the possibility of nuclear
war and certainly the possibility of
overpopulation and it might mean it just
and and environmental degradation and
all of that was
that that apocalyptic Vision was what
everyone who paraded themselves as
informed and you know properly
skeptically pessimistic they're all
parading that as moral virtue and for
Simon to come out and say no you guys
just
it's like Elon Musk now coming out and
talking about how uh you know one of the
biggest problems is to be sad as in the
next hundred years is depopulation which
I happen to believe is true I also think
he's dead on with his criticisms about
the un's population uh predictions I
think the U.N predictions are there
there's no evidence they're accurate at
all and even if they are we can handle
the 9 to 10 billion people that will
probably peek out at
um the united nation has been
historically
uh quite uh that their numbers uh have
have have not stood the time the test of
time uh there are other uh demographic
demographers in the world who have done
a better job at predicting uh where the
world population is going to be and the
latest uh bit on this is uh in Lancet uh
which predicts that uh by the year 2100
we are either going to have 9 billion
people in the world we are currently on
eight or uh seven billion um people in
the world so you know it's perfectly
possible at the end of this Century
there will be as many people in the
world as there are now uh obviously the
further out in the future you you go uh
the the less clear those predictions are
but there is another thing that I want
to mention about Jillian Simon because
you expressed an interest in learning a
little more about him it wasn't just
that he was right but he was facing a
lot of personal invective uh from from
the Great and the good uh he was
regularly called an idiot and a fool who
didn't know what a early famously said
that to explain a biology to Simon was
like trying to explain
um the oil Market to a cranberry
um all sorts of other things
um early continue to receive throughout
his life a variety of very prestigious
academic prizes
um only recently he was invited to
Vatican Vatican of all places to get a
talk on the danger of overpopulation
that was like three years ago so
um in spite of being well you know you
don't want to have too many souls to
save so so in spite of being wrong all
the time he just keeps on being highly
highly revered there's one more thing I
do want to say and then I think I will
hand it to Gail because Gail will uh do
a good job of explaining why we thought
that we could improve on the BET
um uh but uh the key that I wanted to
talk about is that in spite of the fact
that Ehrlich lost this very uh visible
and very humiliating wager with with
Simon the idea of overpopulation never
went anywhere yes environmental movement
is incredibly complex there are people
who are extremely smart and and and
well-intentioned like for example
um uh lombork uh or Stephen Pinker they
mean well they are interested in in
technological solutions to climate
problems and uh and I I count myself in
in that kind of sort of universe but
there is an extremist environmentally
subtext or or subgroup in
environmentalism who who uh who have
these apocalyptic obsessions uh so for
example and and this gets translated
into the movies which billions of people
see around the world in our in our book
we talk about how
um with every decade since the 1950s the
number of apocalyptic movies has been
actually increasing which is which is
the exact opposite of what is happening
on earth the earth is getting richer
healthier uh in some ways there's even
environmental Improvement but there are
more and more movies about how the world
is going to end uh in a some sort of a
catastrophic catastrophic apocalypse and
one of them is a very very famous one
and that was the
um uh infinity War which was seen by
something like every fifth American and
that and that movie plot is about a a a
villain who who has these malthusian or
erlikian ideas you have to kill half of
population of the universe in order so
that the other half can survive and so
this is not an academic debate people
around the world are being fed the diet
of malthusianism almost on daily basis
you know what was interesting one of the
things that was interesting about that
Marvel movie and interesting about the
Marvel Pantheon in general is that well
Thanos is a is a derivation of Thanatos
so he's a figure of death and in the
Marvel movie and you might have expected
this given our pop culture
um in the Marvel movie Thanos is clearly
a villain and that's interesting because
even though there is this apocalyptic
tone to the movie he is a villain his
job his his theory that half of
everything has to die in order for the
other half to thrive is put forward and
even in a devil's advocate sort of way
but it's clear that he's an enemy and I
and it one of the things that was so
interesting about the Marvel
Pantheon is that if you look at it quite
carefully it's not politically correct
and it's not apocalyptic
um the the movie for example Scarlett
Johansson's last movie the uh I think
it's the Black Widow
she she is an unbelievably Politically
Incorrect character she's the real
antithesis of this apocalyptic Doom
saying hyper-agreeable culture that that
has produced the sort of movies that you
described like Soylent Green and I
thought that was extremely interesting
because I think there is a Dawning
recognition at the level of public
fantasy that these
um purveyors of Doom are not only wrong
but perhaps murderously wrong and that
we've been LED down the Garden Path in
an approp in an inappropriate way for
about four decades or five decades and
then I have one more thing to say about
that you guys can tell me what you think
of this is that
I think part of the reason too that we
see this apocalyptic Vision popping up
so much now isn't so much because the
apocalypse is nigh in in a sense in that
we're doomed to it is that things are
changing so fast that in some sense the
destruction of everything we know is
always upon us because like are you
willing to make a prediction about what
your life is going to be like 10 years
in the future in in in in many regards I
mean technology has changed our lives so
much and that's that's happening so
quickly that it's unparalleled and so I
think we all feel like well we're on the
edge of precipitous change and it it
might be terrible but while your point
is it might also be extremely good and
and that we could direct it that way
yeah I would just add to that that we're
we're on this cusp of exponential
creative destruction because right we're
having this this destruction but we're
also having this creativity that's
actually on a steeper curve than the
destructive curve well that's what I'm
hoping too you know when I go out in my
lectures I'm trying to tell people is
look we've got we've got everything we
could possibly want in front of us if we
are smart enough to reach out and take
it if we want it someone much of this
environmentalism that you've described
that and I think your work is such a
good antidote too doesn't seem to me to
be pro-flourishing it's there's an
anti-human element to it a hatred of
humanity that that I think is deeply
pathological and resentful and I think
the fact that
Eric's ideas about population excess are
still so popularly
trumpeted forward as uh as as the only
ethical attitude towards the problem of
humanity is an indication of the depth
of that well some of its malevolence as
far as I'm concerned like I've heard
environmentalists say many of them say
you know there are too many people on
the planet the planet would be better
off if there's only a billion people
um human beings are a cancer on the face
of the Earth you know we're like a virus
that multiplies unchecked I mean Jesus
guys seriously man watch your language
you know yeah interesting that you bring
that up because it was really this 1973
erlich comes out with his book in 68 73
they come out with limits to growth this
club of Rome does and interesting that
73 was also the year that Thanos was
introduced in the comic book so the
culture was kind of doing this thing and
um but clubber Rome they come out with
this argument that says look
population's gonna do this and we're all
going to collapse well population didn't
do this and then so they shifted and
said well we seem to be okay
it's pollution that's going to do this
and we're going to collapse and then
pollution goes the other way and they
say well we're going to redefine our
model now to
um it's not pollution we're going to
Define CO2 as pollution
so they keep redefining the model to be
able to predict this collapse and it's
like well well what are you guys going
to do here
we can human population continues to do
this and we life expectancy and
abundance continues to grow and in spite
of your modeling oh you know we got a
psychological problem on our hands here
I think to some degree it might be that
you know human beings are unique and we
we could speak biologically here I
suppose in that we really do we're the
only creatures that really do apprehend
our own finitude
you know and so in some sense we are
obsessed and possessed by the
apocalyptic Vision because we all know
that we're going to die each of us and
that all the all the people we know are
going to die and that everything we know
is going to come to an end and so
that's there as a reality and then the
question is well that's a fundamental
reality and we try to Stave it off we
try to stabilize things and we try to
make our our economies productive and
sustainable and so that we don't die but
we know that
we're fighting a losing battle and it
isn't we don't understand how that
fundamental knowledge of finitude is an
endless source of degeneration of
apocalyptic fantasies or how to manage
that in any real sense you know because
it is the case that we while we
certainly do face limits
personally limits of mortality limits of
time limits of time limits of time which
is the one resource which is actually
getting scarcer
right right right well as as we leave I
mean we obviously live longer but it is
the the one scale resource we know that
that it will it will come to an end yeah
right and and there's only a live
there's a real limit to what we can do
to Stave that off even if we generate a
tremendous amount of money while we
expend our time
right so each each second becomes more
valuable in some sense as you age and
that and and the concept of time is
really fundamental to uh to our work
because uh well I'll hand it over to to
Gail but essentially we were
dissatisfied with the uh with the wager
between uh uh between Ehrlich and Simon
we thought we could do something uh a
little more interesting and a little
different and um I think Gail uh will be
able to explain it better than I can
so in Simon's first book he talks about
or one of his first books he talks about
looking at the price of thing the money
price of things and the problem with
money is money uh loses its value over
time typically so you have to make this
adjustment back to real dollars versus
nominal dollars but he also mentioned
this interesting thing he said uh you
know we can compare it to time and he
said well how much money can you earn in
an hour of time and then take that and
compare it to the price of things so he
talked about the idea of time prices so
that kind of piqued our interest a
little bit and then there was also a
Nobel uh prize-winning Economist William
nordhaus who did this really interesting
study about the price of light and he
said let's look at what it costs you to
earn the money to buy one hour's worth
of light and you can measure light in
lumens and so he does this studying this
light is just doing this
yeah well you said in your book that
that it's so amazing to think of this is
that
one electric 100 watt electric light
bulb is the equivalent in terms of light
generation of 17
000 candles
I mean that's a lot of candles and then
you made some comment too about how much
labor in terms of time it took to earn
that many candles and you can imagine
even now a 17 000 candles
especially if they're made of beeswax or
something like that that that's not
inexpensive yeah so I mean if you go
back to 18 you know we go back to 1800
and it took three I had to work three
hours to earn the money to buy one hour
worth of light
and so the time price was three hours
for one hour today it's like one
0.166 seconds of time yeah same light so
well we think we well we want to point
out what this means too because prior to
the dawn of inexpensive light and also
this obtains in many places in the world
now
the fact that there was no light
seriously delimited the number of hours
you could spend working and so when
you're buying light you're not just
buying light you're buying time to be
productive you can't read without light
you can't write without light you can't
well
it's it's hard for people to imagine
this because we're never we're never
plagued by Darkness ever anymore ever
and you know maybe we suffered from the
absence of the night sky and I think we
do but light is light is basically free
and that means that we have many more
hours per day the you know the other
thing I that really struck me in that
regard it wasn't your work though but
other many people have commented on this
is the absolutely revolutionary
consequence of inventing eyeglasses for
people because many
people in medieval Europe on obviously
across the world
had to do close work like Tailors and
when they're when they lost their
ability to see close like you do when
you need reading glasses they couldn't
work anymore and so this simple
technological innovation of glasses you
know it added 15 years of productivity
to people's lives and then light well
that adds what four hours of
productivity per day and it's free we
see we one of the things I really like
about your your work is that you help me
understand and communicate to people
just how rich we are we're so rich we
don't even know how rich we are
well that's right
um I I think uh you know you talked
about light and productivity which is of
course very important but if you didn't
have light you didn't have anything else
I mean there was no entertainment uh
obviously there was nothing on TV there
were no TVs as you said you couldn't you
couldn't uh read
um uh most people lived in absolute
poverty so they really couldn't afford a
candle and therefore once the sun set uh
you just went to bed
in the yeah in the cold and so and so um
Gail mentioned uh the the concept of
time price and I think it's very
important that we explain it in Greater
depth so here's the deal uh you know we
we buy things with money but we really
pay for them with our time
so there are money prices and there are
time prices and it's pretty it's pretty
easy to convert a money price to a Time
price you just take the money pricing
you divide it by hourly income so for
example if something costs 20 and you're
earning twenty dollars an hour the price
of that is one hour so money prices are
expressed in dollars and cents time
prices are expressed in hours and
minutes and this offers you know a
number of features first of all uh we go
to this Universal standard of time and
it's not it's not you can't counterfeit
it you can't inflate it it's this
constant flow so everybody recognizes
what an hour is we have this kind of
perfect equality of time we get 24 hours
a day yeah and that's independent of any
real socio-cultural differences it's
because well we all suffer from the same
degree of finitude in some sense so yeah
yeah and I'm amazed well I can't believe
this I know that
it's a very tricky business for any
academic Enterprise to get its
fundamental units of measurement correct
it's it's it's of absolutely crucial
importance that that be done like the
periodic table of the elements for
chemists for example and maybe the five
Factor personality model for for
psychologists
um or and IQ as well these fundamental
measurements and so but it is kind of
surprising to me that you Economist
types didn't figure this out until
recently like what what was in the way
well Julian Simon had kind of figured it
out and actually Adam Smith talked about
this in his his wealth and uh Wealth of
Nations he talked about the fact that we
have to buy things with our labor which
is really our time and you know the
other feature of time I think we've got
what seven uh Universal standards of
measurements six of those seven all go
back to time so we're trying to move
we're trying to move the thinking back
to this Universal standard of time so
once you've established a Time price
then it's it's the comparison of that
time price over time you know it cost me
one hour a year ago today it only cost
me 45 minutes you know so the the
percentage change in that time price is
really what what we should look at and
then it's the ratio of the ratios that
we we look at
um you know uh if something is
um goes 75 off for example it's like
okay 75 off that's that's interesting
that means for the for the time that it
used to take to earn one unit now I get
four so going from it's a 75 decrease
but you think about it the other way
it's actually a 300 percent increase in
your abundance because I I used to get
one now I get four right right and
there's a moral claim there's a moral
claim here too that we should be very
careful to make explicit I would say
which is
if we've accepted the proposition that
something is worth having
it's worth it's useful and uh
justifiable to assume that if we can
produce that more efficiently that's
good right those two things seem to go
right together so because we I think
when you're trying to nail down
something like fundamental measurement
you have to nail it down all the way to
the ground if we agree that there are
good things to have
so we have good and have as agreements
then we're also going to agree that if
we can get good things to have with less
expenditure of the most fundamental
resource that also constitutes a good
and that would part be partly because
well there are lots of good things we
like and need to have and so if we have
more time we can get more of them too so
there's there's really no way of
subverting this claim I would say if you
accept the initial proposition that
there are good things that you know we
can and should have yeah exactly so once
we once we kind of got this time price
figured out and said you know we should
take all of these uh prices that we have
and convert them to time prices and then
see what happens so we go back to
Simon's original bet we're kind of
inspired by that and one of the
critiques of Simon's work was you know
you were just lucky Simon because it was
only for 10 years and it was only for
five Commodities and so we said well why
don't we expand it from 5 to 50. so we
went beyond just these medals and we
went to energy we looked at food we
looked at materials we looked at other
metals so we developed this data set of
50 Commodities that are tracked by
the World Bank tracks these prices so we
and the the we could go back in time and
look at all other data okay so I gotta I
got to ask you a political question real
quick about that so you know
I'm obsessed with measurement because I
was a psychometrician when I used to be
a university Professor when that was
still possible and uh I've always been
skeptical of the measures that
politicians use to assess the economy
both unemployment that I'm skeptical
that measure I'm very skeptical of
inflation measures not in and of
themselves but I'm not convinced that
those are sufficiently valid measures
reliable and valid measures to base our
entire economic analysis on and so I'm
wondering is if if you convert
um the cost to cost in time and
standardize it in that manner can you
then rank order countries if you take a
let's say a 50 commodity random sample
of fundamental Goods can you then chart
a progress graph of of countries
relative move towards prosperity and you
do that year by year can you derive
yearly indexes and are those is that a
good replacement for something like
inflation if the inflation rate
assessments take a look at page 142.
we've got uh we've got 42 countries that
we've done that with
so we we go from Argentina to United
States and look at all these different
countries and measure what their uh
income is doing their hourly income is
doing with these commodity prices I
would go back to great man yeah the
World Bank commodity prices you know
those are public prices so everybody
there's no disagreement that these were
the prices of those Commodities and then
the next question is what do you use for
the denominator below uh you can use a
country's local reported average hourly
income uh in this case we we're trying
to get a number that we could use as a
proxy for the whole planet and what we
finally came up with is let's look at
GDP per capita per hour
so how much do you have generated on the
planet per hour worked and let's use
that as an index or a proxy for how
productive people are getting because we
also note that when Innovation occurs it
shows up both in lower prices and higher
incomes
so
it's important that the time prices are
actually capturing both of those values
because it's the ratio of those two
numbers so time prices actually contain
more information than just a money price
so this graph or this graph these data
this data that you talked about on page
142 you show for example that change in
resource time price in China it was not
point it's negative 97.5 percent and
China's at the top of the list and so
there's tremendous number of developing
countries that are leaping forward so
but but it's I would also suspect maybe
this is wrong but tell me if it tell me
if it's right or wrong
uh there must be low hanging fruit to
some degree when a country does emerge
from its agrarian past let's say a
non-industrial past into an industrial
present and
free up its markets and move into the
modern capitalist age free market age
and so
China South Korea Sri Lanka Ireland does
extraordinarily well is there any way of
adjusting that for Baseline Prosperity I
mean the Americans have done as well as
the Chinese but they started off a lot
better let's say in the last century
right and you can make those comparisons
you can put them side by side I think
that the interesting thing for us is
what are the slopes doing in these
different countries I mean yeah the
United States has got this this lower
rate of growth but all of these other
countries are catching up at such a
rapid rate that that there's none of
these countries that are actually going
the other direction
and yeah something eh yeah it really is
so
um now now the now the key with China uh
is to remember that uh China and India
China has done spectacularly well over
the last uh 40 years
um uh and and uh so has India it's very
important to remember that those two
countries were actually the most
populous countries at the time when they
were super super poor in other words if
you're right China if you looked at
China in 1960 or India in 1960 they
already had Mass populations but they
were super poor so what happens super
abundance is not simply an outcome of
adding more people to the world although
that's important
it's people times Freedom will give you
very high rates of economic growth now
I'm not suggesting for a second that I'm
not suggesting for a second that China
is a free Society but what I am saying
well it's comparatively free compared to
what it was it is much Freer than what
it was when Mao killed 45 million of his
uh fellow citizens another thing
um another reason why this research is
kind of important is because Gail
mentioned the Club for Growth report
Club for Growth
was read by the Chinese Communist Party
in the 1970s and between delightful how
delightful between 1980 and 2015 they
had this one China policy in place the
Chinese government is very boastful and
very proud that they have prevented or
extinguished 400 million birds in China
between 1980 and 2018. China as well as
world would be much more prosperous
societies if uh if uh if if that hadn't
happened but it was a spectacular
spectacular shot in the foot as you
would expect from a Communist Regime
because what they are left with now is a
very unstable population uh pyramid yeah
whereby the the population is getting
old and there are not enough workers to
support the economy of the size that
they currently have so yeah they also
have a plethora of men which they're
going to pay for too that's a that's a
recipe for social and stability in like
2016 it was maybe it was 2008
um the the the the the the the
um uh the the sex ratio uh peaked at
120 Chinese men per hundred women which
means that 20 of men in China could not
hope to find a Chinese wife and there is
very good evidence suggesting that men
who do not uh have a partner are much
more likely to engage in criminal
activities yes there's very good
evidence for that so one of the really
killer things about this graph on page
142 is you have a column there entitled
years to double personal resource
abundance and so then by your criteria
it's how ra how many years does it take
for you to have to work half as long to
get the same resource whatever that is
and this is stunning this is 1980 to
2018 so basically a 40-year period over
a 40-year period
China's average years to double personal
resource abundance was seven
unbelievable but even countries like you
list India it's 15 New Zealand 19
Finland 20. so that's really certainly
within the confines of well that that's
four dabblings in the average life man
it's deadly and this is even among
developed countries yeah it's really and
the average was the average was 20 years
now some people may say that uh doubling
of personal abundance now we are not
talking about you know we are talking
about resources resources include things
like beef rice coffee tea uh milk uh
oranges bananas whatever now some people
may say that doubling of abundance every
20 years is too slow but this is where
at least at least a cursory
understanding of history is very
important people need to understand that
homo sapiens has been around for 300 000
years and our standard of living was
stagnant for tens or even hundreds of
thousands of obvious nothing has changed
exactly the same amount of food and
resources that your your parents could
buy you would be able to buy your
children would buy so by historical
standards the kind of appreciation in in
abundance the kind of doubling of
abundance of 20 years uh is actually
well it's close to a miracle it's a it
is a miracle it's unparalleled and it is
really important to drive that point
home I mean
people think that
they tend to think of human of change in
human societies as the norm and that is
in some sense true compared to animal
societies which just don't change at all
I mean a Grizzly now is exactly the same
as a Grizzly was 60 000 years ago for
all intents and purposes but you know
even in
very technologically advanced cultures
like ancient Egypt
uh which was a much faster developing
country let's say uh Society than the
typical Stone Age Society there were
there were periods of time in the
Egyptian archaeological record that
exceeded A Thousand Years where there's
zero evidence of any technological
change whatsoever
and so there are there are and then if
you go back let's say to so-called Stone
Age civilizations
there's good anthropological evidence
for the Persistence of some rituals
which left a certain uh uh
archaeological Mark Persistence of those
rituals unchanged over twenty thousand a
year period so the rule in biological
systems is lack of change at the
cultural level and even among human
societies generally speaking rates of
change are unbelievably slow and so for
people to say well you know doubling
every 20 years isn't fast enough it's
like well a compared to what and the
other thing to think about is how fast
and doubling do you think we can stand
you know because some of that is
I know you think well oh no we're
getting prosperous too fast isn't that a
problem if that's a problem you need to
have if you have to have a problem but
it is challenging you know I mean
because our society is changing so
rapidly now it's actually hard for
people to keep up with it
you know they get superannuated in some
sense so
in any case it's a remarkable it's a
remarkable set of observations and it's
very difficult to to look at this
without
being being really sad I would say in
some sense that
we had to
swallow so much apocalyptic nonsense for
so many decades to the detriment of so
many when the evidence is starkly clear
that more people in Freer markets solves
all the problems that everybody wants to
solve faster than anything we've ever
produced by a large margin
I should like to point out of course
that
um whilst I'm cautiously or perhaps
rationally optimistic about the future
nothing in what Gail and i writes should
be understood as a guarantee that things
will go on improving in the future at
the rates that we have seen before
um you know in our conclusion of the
book we identify three critical problems
to maintaining uh super abundant growth
by the way we should we should probably
at some point uh Define what we mean by
super abundance but but the three very
important uh components of how we can
ensure that super abundance continues
well first of all
um we we cannot have a population
collapse uh which is something that Elon
Musk uh continues to warn against now in
the book we don't say that uh you know
we don't take a we don't take a position
on what is the optimal size of the
world's population uh but what we do say
is that parents when they are making
decisions about having babies that those
decisions are not made in a vacuum
um when when parents are being told that
bringing an additional child into the
society is a crime that you are hurting
the planet and the rest of your species
uh if if if if that's what parents think
then of course that will have an impact
on their fecundity and in fact we now
have studies uh that have been conducted
or rather opinion polls that have been
conducted over the last four years
um and they show that people do take
environmental apocalyptic uh warnings
into account when making decisions about
where to have babies or not
um the the second the the second problem
that we need to avoid if we are going to
remain super abundant is of course
freedom of speech freedom of speech is
absolutely fundamental it is not only
fundamental on a on a personal level uh
if you cannot uh speak freely you cannot
think freely you cannot express yourself
freely but on a societal level
um if you are following an idea of the
cliff like Lemmings do
um you know it could be a bad idea
um it it if it's a bad idea then you are
going to end up like going off the cliff
right
um that was the problem in communist
societies I grew up under communism part
of my life and uh because we didn't have
freedom of speech people couldn't point
out that the society was actually
stagnating and in some ways
retrogressing and we couldn't come up
with a way of resolving our problems and
get on on a on a better path and that is
why uh Speech codes and banning of
expression of ideas no matter how uh no
matter how offensive we may find them
after all heliocentrism was offensive at
one point in the past but but if we
prevent these ideas from being aired
then we don't know really some of them
may be very good and we should we should
we should remember them and the third
um we should learn from them and the
third uh potential problem for super
abundance is of course if the market uh
gets uh destroyed through over
regulation or socialization and the
reason for that is very simple
markets uh provide us with signals about
what's valuable and what's not markets
allow us to see which Innovations uh are
going to be useful and which Innovations
are going to be useless this is what's
called the price mechanism in a free
market economy prices tell you exactly
what you need more of like baby formula
in the United States or um you know oil
and gas when it goes up that you need to
produce more of that but uh if
Government right then that's a that's a
signal we should point out because it's
so important for people to understand
you know you you drew a connection
between free speech and free thought
and people often think of free speech as
a hedonistic right in some sense I I and
every other Yahoo could say exactly what
we want whenever we want and maybe
that's for our own you know enjoyment
but that's not it exactly because there
isn't any difference between speech and
thought in a technical sense much of the
thought that we undertake we undertaken
discussions like this where we're
exchanging ideas and modifying them and
communicating and that free speech is
thought and then the question is
well what's thought and the answer that
is well that's how we abstractly adapt
to the Horizon of the future before we
actually adapt to it so we try out new
ideas that might match what's coming at
us that's unpredictable in this virtual
space that's characterized by the
exchange of thought
so that we don't have to die by making
the wrong decisions when when we're
actually forced to act and I would say
we can make that a biological claim
because the prefrontal cortex which is
the home of abstract thought grew out of
the motor cortex and its purpose is to
run simulations of the world and
simulations of potential action patterns
in the world before you implement them
so that you can weed out the Deadly Ones
and not Implement them and so we
actually evolved in the entire part of
our brain which we use socially to kill
bad ideas before they kill us and so
then if you interfere with free speech
you don't get to do that and
free speech is associated with free
markets in this crucial way that you
describe because
it is very difficult to know what's
going to be valuable next as things
change and the way we do that is we
subject that computation to a massive
cognitive instrument which is the free
market hundreds of millions of people
are making decisions all the time right
on the edge of change and if we know the
price of something we're we're as caught
up with the future as we can possibly be
and so if we we interfere with that on
our great Peril because that is the
cognitive mechanism that keeps us
updated I would simply add to that and
then I will hand it over to Gail is that
free speech and free markets are
learning mechanisms when you say
something which is stupid somebody else
can say well that actually doesn't work
and if you are smart you're going to
internalize that comment and you are
never going to you know express that to
you again you are going to internalize
the the truth uh and and the market is a
learning mechanism as well provided that
it's free so it can indicate what works
and what doesn't and it's free so it can
vary right so I think that uh you know
making this connection between free
speech and and the market is it really
it's this idea that wealth is
fundamentally knowledge
um it's the growth and knowledge that
distinguishes us from the Stone Age it's
entirely due to the growth of knowledge
and this is a point that uh one of our
friends George Gilder makes he says
wealth is knowledge growth is learning
and money is time and from those three
propositions we can derive this theorem
that you can measure the growth of
knowledge with time so it's really you
know how do we grow knowledge well
there's also there's also a definition
of knowledge that's rooted in there to
some degree because you might say well
if you can do the same amount in half
the time you're now twice as smart
you have twice as much knowledge that's
like a definition right because the no
the knowledge you'd have to Define
knowledge as useful in relationship to
something which might be the production
of something of value and so if you
could do that twice as fast or with half
as many resources especially time well
then your knowledge is doubled that's by
definition in some real sense right so
we Define abundance is this a
measurement of time prices as they
relate to your adding you must be adding
more knowledge either making the price
the money price is lower or you're
increasing income or doing the
combination of both because it takes you
less and less time to earn the money to
buy that thing and it's a consequence of
this growth and knowledge and that
growth and knowledge it comes from all
over the place it's not just researchers
in the lab it's it's just not professors
it's everybody on the planet is
contributing these little bits and
pieces of knowledge all the time well
look you can tell I'm always I always
find it a miracle to go to Home Depot
especially the tool aisles you know and
you you walk down into aisle and there's
like 5 000 kinds of fasteners
and you think well what does that mean
it means that some somebody
generally male has found some little
problem when he was hanging up pictures
on a wall or trying to get a bolt off of
a particularly recalcitrant piece of
Machinery some little practical problem
and then spent Untold hours figuring out
how that could just be made better and
then you just have shelves and shelves
and shelves and shelves and rows and
rows and rows of that and like I learned
because I've done a lot of house
renovations and that sort of thing I
learned that if it if a construction job
is difficult
that means you didn't find the right
tool because someone out there has
figured out how to do that well and you
can certainly see that with com
obviously with computer software as well
so it is miraculous that this is the
case that's another definition what a
market is the market is a place where
you go to find people that can solve
your problem better than you can solve
it
right right right right right okay so
let's walk through your book again a
little bit in more detail shall we
um
the first chapter
so part one is thanos's deadly idea from
Antiquity to the present and Beyond and
so that's this idea of this intrinsic
limit of growth and the fundamental
pathology of human population and so
we've we've kind of dispensed with that
fairly effectively are we in the midst
of progress are we facing the apocalypse
it well probably both but certainly
we're in the midst of progress
um
and we covered Thanos is the
intellectual and practical progenitors
and Julian Simon and the bet that made
him
famous and in part two measuring
abundance new methodology empirical
evidence and in-depth analysis and so
let's go over the Simon abundance
framework because you've both done
specific work on that and I mean is
there anything that we've started to
cover it have we covered it enough or
are there more things you want people to
know about it Marion you want to talk I
think I'll leave that to um uh I think
I'll leave that to Gail yeah sure
absolutely so we go back to this idea of
time prices let's convert everything to
a Time price and what that allows us to
do in addition is we can apply a Time
price to any product any place at any
time so I can go back to France in 1800
and figure out what the time price was
for a loaf of bread and I can compare it
to the time price of an orange in New
York City or Toronto today so once we've
created these time prices for everything
then let's see what they're doing over
time and that's the empirical so we've
got this framework this analytical
framework that says use these uh convert
things to time prices and then look at
the change in time price over time and
that will tell you what's happening to
individuals what's what's happening in
their life in terms of their personal
resource abundance and that is just this
measurement of well it cost you this
much time uh yesterday it cost you this
much time today your abundance is
increasing by that ratio is the
percentage change in that ratio you know
if once again drops by 75 percent it
means I get four for the price of one my
personal abundance is increasing by 300
percent so take the framework go and
apply it to all of these commodity
whatever Commodities finished goods
bicycles drills and see what's happened
to these uh time prices and yeah so so
let me ask you about that these these
Commodities that you've looked at so
let's first of all Define that so so
we're assuming that people
acquire and work for things they both
need and want and we're going to not
take an a priori a stance of a priority
judgment about that we're going to
assume there's all sorts of things that
people need and want and that there's no
externally reliable way of determining
what those should be and so we'll let
people make those decisions themselves
and and people will vary and be similar
in some ways in relationship to those
decisions
how do you ensure that when you look at
the Improvement in
taught in efficiency in relationship to
production that you've properly sampled
the domain of commodities
okay good question so we started with
this idea of let's just look at these
basic fundamental Commodities that have
not changed over time a bushel of wheat
a ton of iron ore uh let's start with
those because if we were going to go
someplace uh uh you know some island off
in the Pacific what would you want to
take with you well you want to have
these basic Commodities that's where we
came up with this basic 50. and let's
subject that basic 50 to this okay I
want to dig in I want to dig into that
more because it's really important right
because this is in some sense the issue
of are you randomly sampling the
environment right so like because you're
trying to take a snapshot of human
progress and and economic efficiency and
we want to we might want to say we might
want to say well do you have the thing
you're taking a snapshot of properly
sample so you pick 50 why 50 and which
50 and how did you Define basic well we
kind of go back to we start with ehrlix
and Simon's bet and says let's look at
those five because they both kind of
Ehrlich said well these are five
non-renewables that you know they should
run out right because they're
non-renewable let's put those let's
let's expand that then let's jump out to
energy let's look at crude oil what's
the price of a barrel of oil you know
for the last we've got really good data
on the barrel of oil it represents this
fundamental unit of measurement in terms
of of the price of energy and then let's
add food to it let's add other materials
to it so what's the price of a two by
four what is the price of a ton of
cotton what are these basic fundamental
Commodities and we were also kind of
limited to what we could find out there
that had good price data on it and what
we found is you know you go back to 1980
and you kind of have about 50 of these
things that that we have good data on
that we can we can use and okay so you
found you found that you found that that
that that with 50 that was well that's a
fairly large number of resources but
it's also you could get reliable data on
50. could you get reliable data on a
hundred do you know or or did it sort of
top out for you at 50.
yeah no the further back in time you get
you go uh the the the less data you have
on nominal prices so for example by the
time we get to
um uh 1960 we have we have 37 but we
look at that too we look at from 1960 to
2018 and then from 1980 to 2018 just to
satisfy those who may be saying that
40-year period is not substantial enough
and uh to to really do time prices for
that data you need the global GDP
divided by the number of hours of work
which which we do in part of the book
but then and this is critical then we go
back to 1850 and we look at uh prices of
Commodities and food uh in the United
States from the perspective of blue
collar workers and unskilled laborers
now this is very important for a number
of reasons uh very often people will say
oh well you're using average data and
that's skewed by the rich okay so we'll
take those out we'll just look at people
at the very bottom of the income strata
and that's the blue color workers
working in the manufacturing and then
unskilled workers like for example uh
people who clean the hallways janitors
okay now we have wage data going back to
1770s and we have commodity and food
data going back to 1850.
so here's what we found uh I'm just
going to give a few examples
so a blue collar worker between 1850 and
2018 that's page 157. uh rice drops in
time price by 99 which means you now
have 111 units for the price of one unit
uh pork drops by 98.7 which means that
now you have 75 pounds of pork rather
than one pound of pork
um that your ancestors could buy in 1850
uh coffee drop of 98 relative to wages
which means you now get 49 pounds of
coffee for the same amount of work that
would take you to buy one pound of
coffee beef dropped by 85 percent you
now get seven for the price of one so
that's the blue collar worker and we can
also look at the least fortunate uh in
uh well least fortunate employed people
in the United States and that's the
unskilled again an example a sugar
dropped by 99
means you now get 107 pounds of sugar
instead of one pound of sugar in 1850
um rice once again you get 53 the pork
35 36 pounds instead of one corn 26
pounds for the price of one lamb four
instead of one so you know you go over
these um uh stats and what you're
finding is that so long as you have the
nominal price of a commodity in 1850 and
a nominal wage hourly wage in 1850 and
then you come to compare it to 2020 or
2018 or whatever you can see these
Trends and they are the same whether
you're looking globally or in the United
States
yeah you said you say when you're
looking at uh Jack's 26 Commodities here
between 1850 and 2018
the average pra increased by
57 basically 5 800 percent so yes that's
personal resource abundance correct
right right and the numeric equivalent
of that the dollar equivalent of that is
the the hourly compensation rate Rose
from six cents an hour to 32 dollars an
hour so but they but the pra personal
Resorts abundance uh index would be a
more accurate gauge of that Improvement
so the Improvement is
it's very difficult I think for modern
young people in particular to really
understand how poor people were
absolutely
yeah absolutely the best the best
example I like to use is the sugar
example and it's like well the time it
took you to earn the money to buy one
pound of sugar in 1850 how many pounds
do you think you could get today I'd
love to serve my students on this and
they'll say oh like two pounds or four
pounds you get 227 pounds
it might explain why we're also fat is
because sugar has become just
tremendously abundant and uh you know
but but it's not just sugar it's all
these other ones uh you know the the
average the price has fallen by 98 which
means you know for the time it took you
to get one unit you get 50 units right
right right right right so and so okay
and so well let's continue with this so
um why why super abundance why why that
title
well I I well should I take it okay I
feel like I'm talking too much you
should tell me to shut up but look
um it's very simple
um if if early was right which he wasn't
uh abundance of resources would be
declining Simon was right abundance is
increasing but abundance can increase at
two different speeds
if abundance of resources what we call
personal resource abundance
is increasing at a lower rate than
population so if population increases by
five percent but personal resource
abundance is only increasing by two
percent we call that increasing
abundance
but if population is increasing at five
percent but your resource abundance is
increasing by 10 we call that super
abundance
in the book we looked at hundreds of
Commodities goods and even Services
going back all the way to 1850 18
different data sets that we got from
third parties mostly uh so that we are
not accused of cherry picking not all of
them but most of them
all 18 data sets have been growing at a
super abundant speed which means that
our wealth this this abundance is
increasing faster than population and
what that tells us
is that on average every human being's
contributes contributes more than they
consume we are destroyers but we are
also creators and it and it turns out
that we are more of a Creator than we
are a consumer or a destroyer we create
wealth and also also that the rate at
which that is true is increasing rather
than decreasing it is so our data
suggests that the early data sets going
back to 1850 and so on there we have
these increases in in abundance of
resources uh at about two and a half
percent per year
um uh compounded growth rate but by the
time you get to the 1980s and Beyond you
get to about three and a half percent so
so on okay so so now we can tell parents
that means we can tell parents that not
only is your child not going to be on
average a net terrain or the world's
resources not only are you not going to
make other people poorer and the planet
more Barren by bringing another child
into the world that you're actually
doing a positive good is that if you
have 10 children everyone will be
somewhat richer because of that the
chances that they will be richer and the
chances that one of those 10 babies is
actually uh going to be able to
contribute something uh substantial to
the welfare of human beings is higher
than if you just have a one child
right right wouldn't that be lovely and
I do believe that it's the case you know
so it's really that's really something
to be able to tell people you know I'm I
I watched in my own life people react
certainly not positively to pregnant
women talking about their babies their
babies they're going to bring into the
world it's so awful to see you know it's
well how you know and and parents
themselves they have this this
discussion they have with themselves I
suppose
particular moral conundrum for young
women is like well do I really want to
bring a baby into
a world like this and the answer is well
it's it's a world that's getting better
and your baby will probably have a
better time of it than you did or
there's a reasonable probability that
but your baby will also be a net good
for everyone else really like not not in
some naive idiot Hallmark greeting card
simplistic way but really actually
solidly and and in spite of all the
Dooms saying of the malthusians and the
apocalypse and uh and the
anti-capitalists and so forth so that's
a lovely thing to be able to tell people
and that brings us really to the
importance of innovation where I think
uh Gail uh really contributed heavily to
that particular chapter so I think that
I I wouldn't mind if he wanted to talk a
little bit about uh Innovation if you
don't mind
yeah so so here's the idea as we begin
our model thinking about you know it
begins with human beings and we focus on
that because the only source of new
ideas are human beings and those those
ideas really entail how do we create new
knowledge with these capitals that we
have we Define Capital as anything we
can use to create something of value so
you have physical capital human capital
intellectual Capital Financial Capital
cultural capital and so I I begin with
this idea when I can actually manifest
that idea and convert the idea into to
Something Real it becomes this thing we
call an invention but in order for a
taxi move into this Innovation level it
has to go through the market and the
market is really where you take these
things and they're tested to see if
you've truly created value and if it
creates value then this invention
becomes an innovation and it's it's in
our progress is entirely due to our
ability ability to innovate okay so
Lumber glomberg has showed this I think
is dovetails with your work uh so when
Lombard's done his
return on investment rank ordering of
solutions to the problems that beset us
he showed that the highest return his
economists calculated for investment in
the future was investment really into
Early Childhood care some of that was
early childhood nutrition and part of
the reason for that as far as I can tell
is that
well if a child's growth is stunted in
early life because of malnutrition one
of the things that happens is they don't
develop their intelligence their
intrinsic intelligence to the degree
that that's possible so there's been a
walloping increase in the average IQ of
the human population over the last
century and a huge part especially at
the lower end which has been brought up
and a huge part of that is that well
there's just so many fewer people
suffering from absolute privation and so
if the most valuable resource that we
have is the capacity to innovate then
the most the most logical problem to
Target is that which might interfere
with the development of say General
cognitive ability in childhood and it
turns out that that's actually quite
inexpensive to Foster and so
that that that fostering of innovation
there's lots of things that have to do
that but one of them is definitely a
concentration on Early Childhood
nutrition let's say and it really goes
back to this ability can we get people
to be able to uh learn more or discover
and create new knowledge and if they're
if they're healthy if they have light if
they if they have these fundamental
physical needs met then they get on
these learning curves and the
interesting thing about a learning curve
is whenever you double the output of
something cost per unit fall between 20
and 30 percent and so you're really
seeing the more we make the the cheaper
that we can make them so we we we think
about how do we actually grow an economy
Moore's Law we refer to that all the
time but it's really a function of
quantity it's not a function of time
it's because we're making these chips at
such high quantities every time we
double production that cost drops by 20
percent we're just making trillions and
trillions of these chips well this is
okay tell me what you think of this guys
so I've been thinking about
justifications for inequality economic
inequality because you have absolute
privation as a problem and and the free
market is really good at ameliorating
Absolute privation there's no doubt
about that but there's still a fair bit
of relative economic inequality and so
you might say well those rich people
like do we really need to people who
have billions of dollars and I think
well we might need Elon Musk like you
know that's that's something we could
all think about but in any case here's a
reason we need some people to be
extremely rich I mean when cell phones
first came out I think they were like a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
piece when when they were hooked
directly to a satellite Network and you
know they're big and bulky and only the
most uh wealthy could clearly afford
them and use them productively given
that given their great expense but what
was what was what like five years later
everybody had one and now they're not
just cell phones there's these stunning
technological Miracles that are well
they're they're they're just beyond
comprehension what those things can do
but it isn't obvious to me at all that
everyone could have ever got one if only
a few people
you know if we weren't willing to put up
with the fact that only a few hyper
wealthy people could have them to begin
with and maybe we can't get
really Innovative technological uh we
can't really get make Innovative
technological progress at the commodity
level unless we have pools of people at
every level of wealth so that we can
produce a market for something new among
the hyper rich
before we can produce enough of it so
that everybody can have it and so is
would that mean that inequality does
that imply that economic inequality is
actually a prerequisite for the mass
production of Highly complex
technological
um gadgetry let's say for for everyone
yeah you know yeah here's what I'd say
Miriam is uh look these new Innovations
come out and you have typically these
these significant fixed costs up front
to make the first year yeah yeah yeah
and who pays for that the rich pay for
that and then the marginal cost the not
the cost to the next one that falls
dramatically think about software think
about some of these uh apps that cost
you a million dollars to create the app
but the cost for the next copy is a few
cents
the first one cost the first one costs
you know yeah 100 million dollars and
the millions one costs 15 cents but you
have to get you have to ratchet your way
down that price uh uh ladder yeah who's
gonna do that for you it's the rich that
are willing to put up those costs of pay
those prices up front well and then well
you think too and then if if it wasn't
you could say well maybe government
pools of capital could manage that but
it's not the case because like
government isn't going to buy enough
massive flat screen TVs when they first
become available because the government
doesn't consume like an individual
whereas a rich person in some sense does
right because they'll go after consumer
products and so I don't think we can
replace the benevolent utility of some
people with massive pools of capital
with any
communal replacement see I I think yeah
the difference between rich and poor is
five years right yes yes you know I get
it today Well everybody's going to get
this in five years yeah and maybe in 10
years it'll be two years I I remember
very distinctly a conversation I had
with a very close friend of mine about
20 years ago we were driving
and he said how long before
um access to Internet becomes a basic
human right and of course today in the
United States government pays people who
uh cannot afford access to broadband
internet out of the government pocket it
has basically become a basic human right
as far as Americans are concerned
um let me say one thing about uh by the
way by that I don't mean that I buy into
Universe into these things as human
rights what I'm saying is that people
perceive it as as a human rights but I
think that the the importance of the the
discussion between equality and
inequality is actually much deeper than
that
equality I'll be very Frank equality is
stasis it's another word for stasis
inequality inequality is in my view uh
the Midwife of progress
well certainly the Midwife of of trade
because if we're completely equal we
have nothing to trade uh well yes but
but in in so many different ways uh
inequality is the Midwife of of human
progress uh by that I mean uh primarily
material but maybe maybe some other as
well let's say that you have a society
which is completely static I'm just
going to come up with with an example of
everybody living in a cave and then
somebody decides well I have this great
idea of actually building a a Hut on a
hill with a better View and and so forth
there is an inequality of housing there
going on for a little while whilst
whilst other people realize that they
they can improve how they live their
lives
um in production in uh in in even in
personal Behavior if you have a society
which which which is static and and
doesn't change and somebody realizes
that hey maybe this form of behavior
like learning reading books can read can
lead to a better life that in itself is
a way of inequality when when a company
uh decides that instead of relying on
human labor creating pins we are going
to buy a machine that is going to create
an inequality or production process but
that is in itself going to move the
society forward so right so you're kind
of so you're basically pointing out that
as a as a positive change begins to
manifest itself in a society it first
manifests itself as a marked inequality
it has to because it can't appear
everywhere at once yes because so and
the equality basis it it means that
everything is the same and an inequality
is the disrupter it tells people that
things can be done differently now some
people make stupid choices and they
suffer the consequences but if those
choices are good uh you can become
fabulously rich or important in your
community because you have figured out a
better way of living
and then and then other people are going
to have that five years down the road if
you're a reasonable market player yeah
yeah definitely so the other thing I
would add to this is we go back to
Something Real basic and and I think you
have income inequality but you also have
time inequality and when we look at that
from that perspective it looks much
different so go back to 1960 go to India
uh typical Indian would take about seven
or eight hours a day to just earn the
money to buy their daily rice
and um in the United States in 1960
would take an hour to buy uh the a wheat
and so both of these Commodities have
fallen by 90 percent their time price so
who's better off well the guy in the in
in India he used to spend uh eight hours
now he spends only uh one hour
so he picks up seven hours the guy in
the U.S spent an hour and now I only
spent six minutes he only picks up 55
minutes so the difference in time right
time inequality gets really compressed
when you have this Innovation on these
prices especially when you're dealing
with these basic fundamental food items
the poor or the the primary
beneficiaries of that because now they
have so much more time relative to where
they were 20 or 30 years ago to now go
learn and pursue and be creative and
that's the beauty of time prices not
only is it immune from governments
fiddling around with inflation numbers
but also you can make international
comparisons you no longer have to figure
out what is the exchange rate between
the American dollar and the Indian rupee
um look at the minutes that the people
work there look at the minutes people
work here and that will give you a sense
whether inequality is increasing or
decreasing right right right okay well
let's let's try to cover two more things
before we before we finish
um we haven't got to part three of your
book so that's human flourishing and its
enemies so I want to talk about that and
then
um
the other thing I'd like you to discuss
is well how are you how is your work
being received
both publicly and by other economists so
let's start with the the close off the
the walk through your book we'll go
through part three human flourishing in
its enemies you have four chapters there
one is Humanity's seven million year
Journey from the rainforest to the
Industrial Revolution
chapter 8 is the age of innovation and
the great enrichment chapter nine is
where do Innovations come from
population growth and freedom and then
the enemies of progress from The
Romantics to the extreme
environmentalists so I'll let you guys
comment on part three first and then
let's go to reception of your work and
and your hope for these ideas as well
can I back up to part two real quick
absolutely take another piece of the
story that we want to tell all right so
we're going to go back to a bit of
section two Gail's gonna take us on a uh
on a journey through the remainder of
section two okay so if you're on page
222 you'll see this box that we
developed and the idea is if we can take
and measure let's put population on the
horizontal axis and let's put personal
resource abundance on the vertical axis
and then let's look at 1980 in say 1980
and let's just index uh the personal
resource abundance and population to a
value of one so that red that red box
represents the size of the global
resource pie in 1980. so two things
happen first of all your personal
resource abundance is increased by 252
percent so we go up on the vertical axis
but population also increased by 71
percent so you go out on the horizontal
axis so that's a stunning graph it is a
stunning grass it really makes me
realize that it's not 1980 anymore not
1980 at all so when you come you combine
those two the red box is the 1980 Global
resource pie the 2018 green box is is
2018 and you look at the difference and
and you can you can measure those two in
our our total abundance that green area
that's 500 percent larger than it was in
1980. so the compound annual growth rate
of this uh population level resource
abundance is is almost five percent a
year and what's interesting about that
um is you look at the elasticity in
other words if I increase population by
one percent what happens to personal
resource abundance and we see there that
for every one percent increase in
population your personal resource
abundance increased by three and a half
percent
and the biologists must just hate you
guys eh
well here's the deal is once again the
biologists would have been right if they
would have considered knowledge as the
key unit of measurement instead of atoms
if you measure knowledge so information
information
rather than just pure matter right it's
it's it's this knowledge that can grow
not only can It Grow it can be shared
with another person that's not rivalrous
in other words you and I can share the
same knowledge so we get this ability to
create this substance
that we can share with each other that
it doesn't you know if I have a Snickers
bar and I give it to you I lose it but
knowledge there is no reason for that
there was no reason for the biologists
to presume except that they used bad bad
animal analogies let's say that the same
units of biological activity would
necessarily require the same units of
cost I mean so so we're not well modeled
by yeast and we're not perhaps well
modeled by rats because we have this
capacity to abstract a good biologist
would say hey that's a fundamental
transformation in the nature of
biological reality it's not something
that can just be hand waved away and and
Malthus did not take that into account
and that means he was wrong biologically
not just economically and I think as I
said before the evolution of the
prefrontal cortex is a good Exemplar of
that a perfect example of the difference
between atoms which are final or finite
and knowledge which is potentially
infinite is the most expensive car in
the world called Bugatti Veyron it costs
18 million dollars when you drive it out
of the the dealership
when you then smash it into a wall
it is a heap of plastic and metal worth
maybe tens of thousands of dollars
the amount of atoms
is the same but they've been rearranged
in a Less Pleasant way which makes the
difference between an 18 million dollar
car
and a scrap of Heap that's the
difference between talking about atoms
and their finite nature and knowledge
which can then recreate and which can
which can arrange and rearrange them
yeah sure sure and what you're doing
there too is offering a real criticism
of the even the notion
or certainly the overuse of the notion
of zero-sum game it's like no no things
aren't finite the way that you've been
conceptualizing finite because it
doesn't matter
it matters how much stuff there is but
it matters even more how the stuff is
organized
and I mean you can certainly see that
when we're you just think about it for a
few seconds about our ability to store
information and never decreasing spaces
and that we haven't hit a limit to by
any stretch of the imagination I mean
hard drive technology just gets
stunningly better faster and faster and
what's the limit to that the plank
length or some unbelievably
infinitesimal uh tiny tiny space you
know that would that would constitute
the absolute physical limit of our
ability to pack information into a given
unit of of say time and space
we're not even we're nowhere near that
yet well that actually leads me to a
very interesting observation made by
Nobel prize winning Economist Paul Romer
who talked about the combinatorial
revolution do I have time to talk about
it very briefly yeah yeah so the uh the
periodic table has about 100 uh elements
uh in it right and
um if you take a simple compound like uh
like a bronze it is constituted only of
two elements which is copper and Tin
right
um and it took us thousands of years to
get to a point where we realized that by
combining copper and Tin we could
actually come up with bronze which was
actually useful for all sorts of things
but now once you start but the the the
the the the the the number of
calculations then the number of Two
element calculations are of course 100
times 99 right it takes a lot of time to
go through all of that once you get to
four elements that means hundred times
99 times 98 times 97 you get to 94
million possible combinations and here
is the astonishing thing
when you start thinking about
combinations of 10 elements
the number of combinations is greater
than the number of seconds
since the Big Bang 14 billion years ago
right
so
we literally we are we are very smart
compared to our ancestors but I think
that when people look upon us in 100 or
200 years time they will think we are
very very stupid indeed because they
will come up with all sorts of things by
having more people more freedom and more
computing power that we couldn't even
imagine so so in some sense you're
making the case that the idea that we
will run out of resources giving
combinatorial given combinatorial
possibility is absurd is the idea that
will run out of music
oh Gail and I have this wonderful uh
Gail take it over because this is this
is one of those things that we are very
proud of right so I always curse my
students how many keys on a piano well
there's 88 keys right well then how many
songs are in a piano
well there's really no songs in the
piano it's a trick question the songs
are in the minds of human beings and
what is that number well it's really
infinite and so if you go back and ask
Thanos or Malthus how many keys on a
piano they say 88 well how many songs uh
Thanos would say well you got 88 keys
you must only have 88 songs
right let's go into this crazy thing so
but but kind of back to the your rule
number four uh about your perspective
and when you say uh you know do we
compare ourselves to who other people
are or do we compare who we were
yesterday this little chart that we
discussed allows us to go back and look
back in time and and it's really the
proper perspective if we look at not who
we compare ourselves against today or
who the who we compare ourselves to out
in the future but look back in time
you'll see that that perspective is
going wow
it is just I'm just I'm just I'm just
scrolling through these these graphs
that as you go farther and farther back
in time it's stunning it's absolutely
stunning yeah and and and so I think the
proper perspective come up with the
proper way to measure and then use the
proper perspective will give you this
completely different picture about where
we where we've come to and the potential
going forward
yeah you guys must be pretty damn
thrilled about this book okay
we are very thrilled but I think that uh
playing for something that Gail said uh
about your rule number four is that
um you see I think that if you compare
yourself to other people today or you
know sort of utopian future where
everything is working optimally for
everyone everywhere at all times
um then that can only lead to envy and
resentment whereas if you compare your
life today in a civilized society to
life before you end up with a different
emotion which is one of gratitude and I
think that what is so fundamentally
um what is very problematic is that so
many people in the world are either
resentful or envious rather than
grateful for the extraordinary uh
achievement that Humanity has made
um already
well let's that brings us perhaps if
we're ready to go past part two to part
three which was well you you one of the
chapters there I think it's chapter 10
let me just get back to the table of
contents here
you said uh
these are
the enemies of progress
from The Romantics to the extreme
environmentalists well first of all so
do you guys do you have any thoughts on
why people
would be I mean are people opposed to
these ideas do they think you're wrong
about what you're saying do they what
kind of criticisms are you attracting
and and why are you attracting them
we're here to ask you that question Dr
Peterson psychologist
that Marion
reasonable job just in in the in the
conversation fragments a few seconds
earlier
um
misplaced Envy is a really big problem
resentment's a really big problem
historical ignorance is a really big
problem
you know I mean people don't know how
bad it was they don't know how far we've
come they're never taught that they're
not taught how Terrible Things Have
Become in many places in the 20th
century like my students in my
personality class these are smart kids
at the University of Toronto they were
well educated by by comparative
standards
none of them knew anything about what
happened in Stalin's Soviet Union or in
Mao's China or in Cambodia no one had
ever taught them and so
so I I think you know young people they
they see inequality in the world
and they see some of the painful
consequences of inequality because there
are painful consequences and then
they're enticed into
finding a quick source of blame that
requires no thought and also enticed
into manifesting a moral virtue that is
neither moral nor virtuous
and so
and then and so here we are and instead
of uh you know I've thought for many
years decades that whenever I walk out
on the street and things aren't on fire
I'm pretty damn thrilled at how stable
and peaceful things are I don't take
electricity for granted I don't take
the Integrity of the supply chain for
granted I truly think these are Miracles
I don't think the fact that the default
interaction between human beings in in
this in the Western World broadly
speaking the default economic
transaction is based on trust I don't
take that for granted that's a bloody
Miracle it took us
hardly any societies have ever managed
that and it took us thousands and tens
of thousands of years to produce that
but I think children our children are so
badly educated by people who have no
idea they have no idea about economics
they have no idea about history they
have no idea about privation or
suffering they're looking for easy
answers and and uh and and people to
blame for the remaining
you know catastrophes of the world and I
think your work is an unbelievably good
antidote to that
and and something to offer young people
that's so bloody positive without and
and that it's you know miraculous and
not naive at the same time like what a
good combination that is well here's
here's the question I love to ask my
students is what would I have to pay you
for you to never use your your your
iPhone and the internet again for the
remainder of your life
and I've never get I've never been able
to get a student to to do it for less
than five million dollars
it's like we have this five million
dollar thing that you own
you're all you're all five millionaires
because you get to walk around with
these devices uh oh yeah definitely you
were you were so prosperous so rich
compared to to anybody that's come
before you how could you not be anything
other than than just just hyper grateful
for the life that we have
well you know I think that one of the
things we need to do about this is we
need to start training young people to
think about themselves as
possessed of more possibility than they
know what to do with and then encouraged
to harness that in in so say well look
you you have all the food that you could
have and you have all the information
that there is
you've got it all in front of you now
that you have it all in front of you
what's the most noble Vision you can
bring forth to make use of that
possibility
you know and and I know some of the
research I've done on helping people
make vision for the future future
authoring program we show them pretty
clearly that you can motivate students
we drop the dropout rate of boys in in
Community College 50 by just having them
sit down for 90 minutes and develop a
vision
so you say look you look at what's in
front of you
way more than anyone's ever had in
history
and some people might have a little more
in front of them than you like certainly
but when you have more than you can ever
use how much do you need
and and and then who should you be to
live up to that well that's you know our
Collective problem at the moment trying
to solve that and hopefully solving it
before we let bitterness and resentment
and historical ignorance get the upper
hand because it's kind of a battle at
the moment
yes in our book we do point to
um a number of people who have made a
tremendous difference in the history of
our species we talk about uh Gutenberg
for example and his printing press uh we
talk about uh what and his uh steam
engine uh we talk about summer wise the
the guy who realized that when doctors
wash their hands they weren't killing
their patients and things like that and
so he had a fun time with that didn't he
didn't he end up like persecuted in an
insane asylum and died a miserable death
for all his advances advancing Humanity
that's right uh that's right uh it
certainly wasn't accepted
um at the time just like Galileo's
observations and whatever but
um but I think that if if this book
could
um imbue young people with the
understanding that they have worse that
they have something to contribute that
it is more noble to apply yourself to
changing Society for the better rather
than constantly bitching about problems
in society that you don't intend to do
anything about except to complain and
and go on marches you know do something
something proactive if you if you see uh
that there are children in in Africa
dying from a uh from a curable disease
go and join uh the group of people who
are going to discover a cure to it or
whatever
um yeah or figure out how the bloody
faculties of Education I've been
thinking about this for like 10 years
you know with our computer technology
every single child
I would say on the planet but certainly
in the in the states where everyone has
access to computational equipment
every single child should be an expert
speed reader because computers could
train children to automate letter
phoneme and word recognition
perfectly rapidly because computers are
great at math practice and if the
faculties of Education had an ounce of
Integrity they would have been working
diligently on the problem of getting
children over that hump because there's
a hump in reading comprehension a
because to begin with like there is when
you're learning how to play music
you have to automate
letter recognition and syllable
recognition and word recognition and
then phrase recognition so you get a
phrase and it go at a glance as soon as
you've got that you can start to read
for meaning it's no longer effortful and
then as soon as you can read for meaning
of course it's it's just as
engaging as watching a movie which
people obviously don't have to be taught
to do and so there are all these
problems that are laying out there in
the world and people have a set of
problems that bug them that they could
be working on fixing and they have all
this technology to fix it it's like
that's that's what you want to do is
figure out what what you think needs to
be fixed and then take all this wealth
that you've had put at your disposal and
fix it man and then you got something to
do with your life and we could start
with the proposition that
it's good that you're around how's that
you're not a cancer on the face of the
planet and you don't have to hang your
head in shame because you're ruining
everything quite the contrary that's
actually wrong
and I don't just mean wrong morally I
mean wrong in the sense you guys have
pointed out it's wrong technically no
that's wrong those biologists got it
wrong uh our Innovation uh our
Innovation framework
um is of course uh embedded in a
national culture and let me say a few
words about that
um
the cultures go through periods of
tremendous openness to change
technological change
um and Technology of course manifests
itself in great advances in
biotechnology industry whatever even
education but they can also ossify close
themselves off and
Destroy themselves from within a perfect
example of that would be the difference
between song China and Ming China and
the succeeding dynasties some China in
the 12th Century A.D was a tremendous
place of openness and Innovation and uh
and and and relative Freedom it was
during that period that the Chinese have
come up with paper money the compass
gunpowder and then the dynasty collapse
and it was replaced by particularly
tyrannical one
um Ming and successor and China went
into a technological
um downward spiral in which it remained
for the next uh 800 years so the analogy
to the United States I think would be
that in the 1950s and the 1960s uh there
certainly was a tremendously
forward-looking
um uh forward-looking mentality which
talked about flying cars and um uh
travel to the Moon travel to travel well
not just travel to the to the moon but
Interstellar travel and all sorts of
things and uh I I think that especially
in the last
couple of decades uh maybe since the end
of the.com bubble
um
um and and of course the
postmodern Triumph in in universities I
think that that sort of optimism has
been replaced by a sense that
um a personal agency is no longer that
important that uh oh it's worse it's
worse than that Marion it's I've watched
this with young men and you know it's
they're being taught that personal
agency
first of all perhaps doesn't exist that
that's just a cover story for the use of
compulsion and power because that's in
some sense the post-modern claim but
that even if it does exist that all that
agency and this isn't keeping with this
malthusian Doctrine is that well you
shouldn't be
exercising your agency because you're
just part of the world destroying
forests and so it'd be better it'd be
better for the planet it'd be better for
the planet if you didn't exist but if
you have to go to all the goddamn
trouble of existing and imposing
yourself on existence itself then you
should at least have the good sense not
to do anything
and I I do believe that that's the
message especially that young men are
getting that they're a burden on the
planet that and and if they you know if
they if they don't just shut up about
their Good Fortune about being here they
certainly shouldn't go around you know
trying to do anything
because God only knows what will come
out of that and it's so demoralizing
it's so awful to watch but I think the
pendulum is swinging uh back at least a
little bit I mean you have uh your
podcast and your reach uh our book
um had been endorsed by Nobel Prize and
economists a former
um higher level government officials uh
by uh best-selling authors
um and I think that uh especially when
you show people the data and you explain
what they are what they're looking at
and that that it is objective that world
is really getting better not in spite of
population growth but at least in large
part because of population growth uh
they start uh sinking uh thinking very
differently
um and and uh and hopefully this this
particular book will be a bit of an
antidote to that kind of anti-humanism
and anti-natalism that is destroying
generations of of people we didn't talk
about it very much but in the third part
of the book I talk about
um I talk about these new studies on the
rise in so-called Eco anxiety amongst
children
throughout the Western World children
are being scared to death that every
sandwich they eat every holiday they
take is somehow destroying the planet
psychologists are now seeing families
who find it very difficult to cope with
living in the modern world because they
feel that their activity is destroying
the planet
this antenatalist anti-humanist
um
view is deeply damaging not just to the
General
future of our species but to individual
lives of of men women and children in
the world today
yeah it does nothing well the other it's
also it's also it also is
counterproductive in relationship to the
stated goals of the people producing the
anxiety because what happens to men who
are demoralized young men who are
demoralized is that because they lose
hope and then don't put in effort and
become cynical that they their
relationships get fractured and they
have no productive activity and so their
lives get more and more
difficult and and and
cynicism inducing as they withdraw into
this sort of nihilistic negative
Buddhism in some sense and then they get
bitter and then they get resentful and
then they get angry and then look the
hell out
and so because if you push people into a
corner by demoralizing them bubble like
the very nature of their existence
itself or about existence itself it
isn't that they're just gonna wander
away quietly and disappear into the
woodwork like like mice some of them
will do that but others will turn into
unbelievable monsters and we always
threw up our hands and wave around when
we see something happen like happened in
Buffalo it's like well why did that
happen it's like well
if you wanted to know you could know but
you don't want to know it's interesting
you should mention it is because in the
last chapter on enemies of progress we
actually discuss some of the mass
Shooters in the United States over the
last five years or so and many uh have
been uh have been driven by malthusian
concerns uh one of the one of the
shooters in in Walmart I believe it was
in El Paso left behind him a memorandum
saying that there are too many people in
the world and if you want to be good for
the planet we have to start culling
culling uh our fellow human beings well
look man if there are too many if there
are too many people on the planet and
we're facing an apocalypse because of it
well why isn't that the moral thing to
do
you know and people people keep asking
why do these shooters there's lots of
reasons these shooters do what they do
and a lot of it's a real pathological
narcissism but they don't leave behind
manifestos because they haven't been
thinking
they are and they are often possessed by
these these antenatalist and malthusian
ideas there's no doubt about that and
that's part of what they do to justify
their destructive narcissism you say
well I'm look at me I'm you know I'm a
moral Paragon because I'm getting rid of
some of the excess population it's like
well I'm I'm going to view that with a
bit of skepticism thank you very much
but it's not like they're not being
handled handled the handed the
ammunition by the right thinking
biologists in prestigious universities
who Proclaim so self-righteously that
there are too many people on the planet
yeah you go back you go back Jordan to
the Unabomber if you remember him and
his Manifesto and you look at who he was
trying to blow up he actually targeted
research centers that were trying to
come up with uh cures for uh natalist uh
diseases and problems like you could
attack the very source of of new life
because your ideology says there's too
many people
yeah so one of the things we could
conclude with is for everyone watching
and listening if you are possessed by a
set of ideas that's predicated on the
claim that
in some fundamental ontological manner
there are too many people for you
then you should take a serious look at
what you believe because there's nothing
in that that's good and your claim that
that belief is what everyone's sensible
would believe if they only cared about
the planet is like first of all just
exactly what sort of Saint are you and
second of all where the hell's your
evidence for that claim and so yeah I'm
appalled at how frequently those claims
are put forward in universities under
the guise of some Transcendent morality
and some what is worship of the abstract
planet in some sense that makes
absolutely no sense whatsoever and to
sacrifice actual people to that it's
just beyond comprehension
so maybe your book is a blow in the
other direction I know your work has
been so far and like this book looks to
me like something that's really gonna
give those who think differently from
this something really difficult to
contend with so wouldn't that be lovely
it would we are very grateful for the
opportunity to talk about it on your
podcast today yeah well hey I'm so happy
about your work it's so it's so lovely
to see these arguments be made in such a
level-headed manner and so in such a
deep-rooted empirical manner what are
the economists let's are you being
criticized by the occult by Economist as
well like what sort of reception are
your suggestions for the retooling of
measurement metrics what sort of
response are you receiving from
economists for example well when we
present when we present this perspective
the first response is just kind of this
little bit of a surprise it's like no
response and then okay go go in and look
at the data and then come back and tell
us where what we're missing here what do
we what are we missing is there a
problem with the data is there a problem
with our logic uh follow us through on
this and let us know where we've made a
mistake in our thinking yeah yeah yeah
yeah well that's good that's good so
that means that while what that seems to
imply is that well a you haven't made
any obvious mistakes but B your approach
is sufficiently unexpected which which I
think is pretty clear from a cultural
perspective that it's actually going to
take people a while to digest it and
come back with the appropriate
suggestions for improvement you know
real criticism of the of the positive
and useful sort
yeah I would say that so far the book
has been circulating uh for long enough
it's early drafts amongst well-known
economists uh that if there was any
serious uh problem with the methodology
we would have been told and we haven't
so the big test of the book and of the
ideas in it is going to be the market
test is it going to is it going to
succeed or not and if it sells and if
people are talking about it then we'll
know that we are on to something well
how how is your previous book uh the
trends book doing and how many has it
sold
well by standards of of a think tank uh
book
um meaning uh you know full of
Statistics it it sold about I think it's
about over 40 000 copies uh which uh
still makes it one of the one of the
best or best selling thing Time Books uh
you know in in this town but this new
book uh is intended for a general
audience as well the reason why we spent
so much time talking about the history
um about
um you know Thanos for example
um is precisely because we want people
to start understanding how these
pernicious ideas that have been around
for a very long time have found their
way into popular culture and maybe
lodged in the back of their brains
um
um and and and and and that there is no
reason why they should be the real
estate in the brain is precious don't
fill it with uh with stuff which is not
true yeah yeah yeah well okay well today
all right so everyone listening
um we were talking about Marion two
piece and uh Gail Pooley's new book
super abundance and their re-analysis of
the role of human population and human
freedom in producing flourishing in all
Dimensions environmental economic
conceptual all these things we can be
positive about and so I I think it's
great I think the work's great and it's
as I said earlier it's so lovely to see
something so profoundly optimistic
and it's such an effective blow against
this dismal and vindictive anti-humanism
that seems to masquerade as current day
moral virtue and so good for you guys I
hope you sell 5 million copies and that
people dispense with this
malthusian
catastrophe that's been plaguing us for
like a hundred years
so that'd be lovely man
thank you very much thank you to see you
guys yeah Batman yep nice talking to you